baby there's a shark in the water
welcome back to CBS morning's great
white sharks are among the most famous
fish in the sea but a key detail about
their lives has remained a mystery for
centuries researchers have been unable
to find the place where they mate in the
Atlantic Ocean however scientists may be
on the verge of an answer and our Carter
Evans joined the team 12 miles off the
coast of North Carolina for an up close
look at their research
look at that chart it turns out getting
a great white shark to bite is not as
easy as you may think there's another
one right there take a look we're on an
expedition with o search off the Outer
Banks of North Carolina the baits in the
water and so are the sharks this is like
the most exciting slash nerve-wracking
part of it is when they're like really
close to the bait and you're just
waiting for them to grab it but they're
cautious circling the boat for hours at
this point we are literally surrounded
by sharks they are circling the boat
that's the big one that's what
scientists want to catch and it's not
taking the bait it is a buffet that
you've laid out there for this shark and
the thing it wants the most and it won't
take a bite so it just shows you how
deliberate these white sharks are Chris
Fisher founded o search and CBS News was
there when the organization tagged its
very first Atlantic white shark in 2012.
[Applause]
they'll soon hit their goal of 100
captures tracking each one online but
first the team hopes to uncover one of
the white sharks Best Kept Secrets
there's nine white shark populations
around the world and no one has ever
identified a mating site that seems to
be one of the big missing pieces to this
puzzle that's the last big missing piece
yes with centuries of people on the
ocean no one's ever documented this well
this is a 400 million year old secret
the ocean's not going to give it up easy
scientists think it could be happening
right here off the Carolina coast during
the summer migration
to find out they need blood samples you
can see that buoy essentially headed
away from the boat right now there is a
great white shark on the other end of
that line they're going to head out in
the boat now and bring it back here
best guess is female 15 foot that's
exactly what we're looking for
like a dog on a leash the team leads the
shark onto a submerged platform
and the scientists spring into action
they're working like a NASCAR pit crew
out here fast trying to get these
satellite tags installed because they've
only got 15 minutes that they can keep
this animal out of the water they draw
blood and even perform an ultrasound all
while the shark is awake and unsedated I
just want to get right in here and get a
look I mean oh my gosh I mean I've never
been this close to such a massive animal
before Brett McBride is pumping seawater
through her gills to keep her breathing
I mean you've got your hand practically
in its mouth
yeah but you can see that it's fairly
docile they usually are scientists call
this learned helplessness the shark
can't go anywhere so she stops fighting
to save energy can I touch one of her
teeth yeah okay oh my God this is so
weird within minutes the data for 24
different scientific projects is
collected and the shark they've named
Umi the Japanese word for ocean
swims away but those tags scientists
attached will track her movements for up
to 10 years they're the system manager
of the ocean as they go the ocean goes
the ocean is 70 percent of the planet
provides us two-third of our oxygen 100
of our water and billions of people food
every day they are the guardians of our
fish stocks there's no future for us as
humans if there's not a robust future
for our large sharks for CBS mornings
I'm Carter Evans off the coast of North
Carolina
it looks so taxing for the shark I know
we're getting good information but can
you imagine if somebody just yanked you
out of the house stuck something down
your throat started throwing water on
you taking all these measurements you
know we have that series try something
new are you interested in getting on the
sharks
are you sure no I'm good from here
though
400 million year old mystery Nate you're
right let's talk about sharks baby so
basically how sharks have sex yes yeah
we can figure that out we can figure the
ocean out which can help save us let's
talk about you and me we got it